[Music]
Andrew Bogut was the first pick in the
NBA Draft back in 2005 he won a
championship in 2015 with the Golden
State Warriors he's just signed with the
Dallas Mavericks and he doesn't like
social justice warriors very much Andrew
welcome to the Rubin report what's going
on I'm doing well how you doing yeah
going alright rolling it into the house
so getting settled here in Dallas yeah I
want to get into a little your Dallas
move but before we get into Dallas let's
just finish up a Golden State are you
still in pain I mean losing game seven
three one lead
how you feeling oh you know we want to
leave before and last season was going
to stay with my season goal to stay - we
obviously were in the in the Box seed
and didn't finish it off and that's
that's kind of the spectacle of sport
but obviously with a new club now and a
new team and look at a kind of achieve
different goals yeah so you are with
Dallas Mavericks and when I saw you sign
with them the idea of you being on the
team owned by Mark Cuban makes a lot of
sense to me because these are two people
who pretty much have no filter is he
like your dream owner yeah we definitely
don't have a filter box turning it down
a little bit now he's I wouldn't be
surprised if he runs in 2020 or 2024 but
now if you heard it here first I like
this yeah it's cool I mean they they
really treat you well here world-class
organization Iran knows and he's those
stories of how well they treat their
players and and they they invest a lot
into trying and trying to help you be a
better player so you always respect an
organization like that and ownership
good like that
yeah is there any risk like when you're
thinking about where to play that when
you hear even though you hear the bar
Cuban treats the guys well and you know
everything's first-class and all that
stuff just having an outspoken owner
that is there any risk when you when you
make your decisions yeah it wasn't
really my decision about bouncing a
trade format but I've definitely enjoyed
it so far he I think you know mark
obviously is very very passionate I'd
rather have a passionate owner any day
of the week and there's someone who's
just using it as a
you know as an investment or you know a
talking point for their friends he's he
he wants to win as much as what he doing
and that's that's a great thing about
having him involved mean some people
don't like that because they think that
you know he's in the spotlight more than
he should be but he's around almost
every other day he says course ID using
our Huddle's and he really wants it to
be a winning organization year in year
out and I think he's done a great job up
until this point yeah so I know that the
stuff that you really want to talk about
and what we first connected with over
twitter is the social justice warrior
stuff but before we get to that you are
Australian in case they can't tell by
your accent those who don't know you I
had read a Panahi on who's an australian
columnist a couple weeks ago and I think
she's just great I mentioned to her that
my neighbors on both sides are
Australians I'm surrounded by a lot of
Aussies I what what do people not know
about Australia that they should know
because I feel like we just don't talk
about Australia in America ever
besides you know Crocodile Dundee
exactly right we have buildings we have
televisions we have all that we have all
that stuff believe it or not it's not
just kangaroos running out on red dirt
so I hear a lot of cultural
appropriation when it comes to Australia
so it gets pretty interesting but you
know it's a little America in a lot of
ways you know it's it's very build up
City wise we have you know five or six
major cities in each state predominantly
most people live close to the coastline
within a couple of hours drive of it so
Central Australia is you know bring
unpopulated because it's very very hot
there and there's not a whole lot to do
there so there are all big cities in
there but Britain middle America with
everyday life you work at 9:00 till 5:00
you had weekends office there with your
family you know elementary school we
call a primary school and secondary
school high school or kind of the same
same kind of system so it's very similar
probably just a bit more kind of relaxed
and children in the states is yeah more
surfing over there I think yeah much
more much more outdoor stuff yeah yeah
Rena described Australia she said she
actually thinks it's the most tolerant
nation on earth as someone that's lived
there and lived in America which I know
we got our problems and we're gonna get
into some of those problems but do you
sense one is more more tolerant than the
other
well Australia is very taller I think I
mentioned this on a couple different
ideas that I've done and my high school
one at almost 100 different
nationalities just my high school I grew
up in an area that was very
multicultural Melbourne itself is a huge
multicultural city and it's great you
get to experience different cultures
different religions different stigmas
from different countries different foods
different types of music and I really
enjoyed it and for the most part people
get along but obviously every now and
then when there's politics overseas and
wars overseas every now and then you
might have little run-ins in high school
yard with that kind of stuff but for the
most part it's it's it's very very
children equal yeah I were you always
big I assumed you were probably pretty
big back in high school right you know I
was up and down I was big early on and
then it's thought a high school I was
kind of smaller and then shot back up so
but for the most part was pretty big so
the older kids usually got stuck into me
a fair bit thinking that I was older
than it was so that probably worked
against you for the older kids but then
you probably got to bully some kids that
were smaller than you I know I'm not
probably not supposed to say that but
you probably had some fun night kids a
kids man
yeah it was a lot of little scuffles in
the schoolyard and we all lived and grew
up from it so you know I'm still living
and and living an okay life as I'm sure
most other people are but I'm you know
both ends of that yeah and you know for
me too I was completely on both ends of
bullying I was bullied by the kids that
were either bigger than me or more
popular than me and I was kind of right
in the middle and I bullied the kids
that were either smaller than me or less
popular or whatever that's just part of
growing up right everyone seems to be so
afraid of that
but it's really just part of growing up
I wouldn't even call it bullying I mean
obviously you don't want to get to a
point where a kid you know he's gonna do
harm to themselves or whatever but you
know this especially in Australia like
we first of all we make fun of everybody
else but but we make fun of ourselves
just as much I think in high school you
go be able to take a joke as well as
well as people joke and I think in high
school we filled that out pretty quickly
but it was you know we don't really have
any huge cases of all this stuff that's
in the media lately with kids and
depression and all that kind of stuff
and you just kind of go on with it
obviously you can't condone you know one
kid getting picked on by the whole
school that's always always a tough
situation but you know sometimes I go
one one one kid he come back at me and
that was kind of everyday life you know
you have you know bruised elbows and
cuts everywhere from scuffling in the
schoolyard and that was the norm
condoning violence by any means but as a
part of growing up as a kid you that's
just something that was everyday nature
to us in Australia anyway yeah do you
think sports is kind of the great
equalizer on all this stuff you know
where everyone would wear all the social
justice warriors want to you know
separate us by religion and color and
ethnicity and background and all of that
stuff and and and financial background
all that that's sports it's like if you
perform I think generally speaking
sports and athletes that's basically as
tolerant and as accepting as it is they
just want you to win and play well yeah
no doubt I mean wings most important
thing when it comes to sport you don't
perform well you really get traded or
cut or moved on and if you're performing
well everyone wants you so is that is
that five minutes that you have to
realize when you're in it to try to
extend it to ten minutes and then
there's times where you know five
minutes gets shortened because you you
know you're out of the league so it
works on both ends the owners obviously
and the GM is one who that performs to
your best of your ability but there's
times where you bite up an injury or
something's gone wrong off the court
with family and kids and wires and light
kind of stuff so it's a tough balance
but sports probably the you know the one
thing where you know it's it is what it
is it's still somewhat pure and its own
sensor although it is sudden become very
political but you know that's why I
always like sport because you could get
in trouble at school you could get in
trouble with your parents but on a
weekend you go and play basketball you
can't forgot about all that yeah so as
it's getting more political as someone
that's outspoken and now will jump into
some of that kind of stuff are you ever
encouraged by coaches managers agents
any of that kind of stuff just to shut
up about personal opinions and not talk
to media and that kind of thing oh no
doubt you know and that's always been
from day one I think there's been some
really prominent athletes in the history
of at least in the NBA that have
I've never aligned themselves to one
side of the other because the way they
saw it is that but both sides support
them and both sides by their shoes so
they didn't want to have any haters I'm
not a guy that's aside to be quite
honest you know I have my principles on
things and how I think but I don't I'm
not left I'm not right on middle I'm
common sense so each and every party has
good ideals good things that they can
they can bring for their people and
every party has some you know some crazy
made-up stuff that you never never wish
for your dog so I mean it's it's things
you know I don't I don't myself to
anybody and I just don't put faith in
politicians to change my life yeah I
like that I'm not left I'm right on
common sense we don't have much common
sense these days when you're looking at
our political system these days not a
lot of common sense in there huh well as
much better in Australia to be quite
honest yeah that's what I've heard at
this at this presidential campaign I
mean it's it's it's laughable it's you
know the debate it's the first debate
that I've actually sat down and watch to
be honest with you I wasn't really into
it the last two didn't really follow a
lot of this stuff I guess social medias
made it easier to follow but it was
almost like two high school kids just
throwing stuff at each other and you
know you've got no answers from either
side I don't think one one person has
established themselves as as someone
that should be the president of you know
one of the most powerful countries in
the world and all I can really say is
feel sorry for the voters of the people
because my sure is a good side to vote
for yeah at least you you're at least a
dual citizen Rory are you a three times
citizen are you when you were born in
Croatia right I was born in Australia my
whole family's Croatian so I was brought
up
speaking Croatian with with Connor
Croatian ideals and culture and the food
and the music that was kind of everyday
for me I'm in Australia and then
obviously very proud to be Australian
first and foremost but no I don't have
the Americans here this year so I'm kind
of an innocent bystander in this whole
issue like I get to not have a horse in
the race like in kind of laughs of both
sides right I was about to give you
three citizenships you only have one so
oh you do have two what's wait what's
the second limit Australian equation oh
so you do have Croatian even though you
weren't born there you actually have
Croatian
far back to date his Croatians gotcha so
actually when I was doing a little
research on you and I saw the Croatia
thing I saw that you you were a big fan
of Drazen Petrovic who was one of my
basketball heroes when I was a kid and
originally I was I was a Trailblazers
fan and Clyde Drexler was my hero and
Drazen was his backup but he obviously
got success in Jersey and what I wanted
to talk to you about and this is related
to all the social justice warrior stuff
and and just nations and our prejudices
and all that there's that great ESPN 30
for 30 I don't know if you saw it about
Drazen and Vlad ad BOTS and Croatia and
Yugoslavia and all that so as somebody
that's played in international games
forgetting how hostile it can be when
you go to you know you go to Oklahoma
City when you're playing in for the
Warriors or whatever when you're playing
for the Mavs but what about the
international element of sports and what
you guys face when a situation like that
where where Drazen and and Vlad a we're
friends at one time and then because the
outside circumstances just all hell
breaks loose yes a tough one Australia
is a relatively young country so I
haven't experienced that playing for
Australia we haven't been to war with
anybody you know at least in the past
20-30 years whereas a Croatia Serbia one
is a very interesting one when it split
up and you know recommend and you want
to watch that documentary to have a
chance I played I actually play with
Toni Kukoc for a year who was on that
team and you know he has some crazy
stories you know he had friends I said
hey you know if you talk to this if you
talk to Vlade and your friends are then
publicly
you're not friends with us when you come
home to Croatia so it's tough it's tough
and I mean I wasn't I was young when the
war happened and I remembered I family
members involved with it you know
cousins and aunts and stuff like that
over there it's tough but we move on I
mean it's in the past and I've actually
are friends at a Serbian I mean I've
Croatian friends that don't like that
and I does a person upon who they are as
a person not by their religion race or
creed and I mean that's that's what
we're missing in today's society I think
everything's judged upon human human
human nature is to judge someone but
when you judge so long without getting
to know them I think we could begin to
the problems that we have to
I love it man you're speaking the truth
so when did you realize this issue with
social justice words I think when I went
when I first reached out to your bio on
Twitter what it said like social justice
nightmare or something or something
funny's what was it something like I
cringe at social justice warriors
privilege or something like that yeah
and I remember seeing that on your thing
and I thought wow I mean this guy this
is not what athletes are usually willing
to throw out there but he did it well
look look I said I don't take sides
I'm just common sense and I've tweeted
some things before with justice warriors
blow up my feet over common sense stuff
and I mean I don't really care like I
mean that the whole these whole issues
of today that they're just not issues I
mean to me the cultural appropriation
stuff I mean I just I just scratch my
head laughing at that because the thing
I want is an Australian where I mean in
America is people to experience the
Australian culture I'm proud of that
yeah I'll turn I'd love for you to try
you know
Australian food Croatian through
whatever it may be whereas people today
are taking that as as offensive or
racist or appropriating a culture but
that's that's the whole point of a
culture of culture is to meet other
cultures and experience different things
and now you're getting punished for
doing that it's just it's absolutely a
discretion to me and that's you know I
just draw a line on it I call them out
on social media and then I get
absolutely smashed with four mentions or
I really don't care yeah so you're
saying if you have a margarita it
doesn't automatically mean that you're
anti-immigrant is that what you're
telling me I just want to say anything I
mean but where does it end what is he's
in yeah I I don't know where it ends it
seems like in everything but do you ever
so you put this stuff out there and then
you get the onslaught of you know all
the the haters and the trolls and all
that stuff and that's fine you're using
your free speech they're using your
theirs
do you ever think I shouldn't even
bother throwing my thoughts out there
cuz what's the point
um a little bit maybe maybe second-guess
putting the tweet out there or saying oh
shut down that but look I'm a man of
principle and I'd rather you tell me how
you feel about me and I tell you how I
feel about you and get on with that day
and that's that's the whole thing with
debates and all that kind of stuff I
think if everyone has an opinion it's
not necessarily right or
but I'd rather have an opinion and I
know your thoughts I don't want the
political crap and then we don't know
where we stand an hour later that's how
I think it should be and that's what
we've got lost yeah the debate is a
prime example it's everything they say
is they're trying to be so politically
correct about offend people for the most
part that at the end of the day what
answers did you get out of that two-hour
debate I've got none I mean then answer
one question he decides he's just
running around in circles you know it's
incredible because it's like oh you got
this one lying this way you got this one
lying this way then the fact checkers
come in and I don't even believe the
fact checkers anymore so we're in this
like weird thing where it almost feels
like we're post truth you just have to
kind of figure out whatever the hell you
think kind of sucks yeah it is today the
Twitter stocks drop 20% in one day and
you wonder why I mean there's more and
more people that are that are putting
their thoughts on Twitter that you know
don't align with Twitter's political
agenda and they get banned and suspended
and that that's what really irks me I
mean I don't agree with some of the
people that have been suspended and
banned with what they've said but it is
their right to have free speech I mean
you can't you can't push one side or the
other and I think you know obviously the
mainstream media is is predominantly
left which is which is a little
frustrating but I wouldn't want to write
conservative or whatever I've actually
tried to google and try find news news
sites that are non partisan or one so I
try to do that yeah good luck good luck
with that you end up in a matrix you
can't you see it's impossible you know
there's one I want to know exactly what
happened I don't want to know you know I
don't want the bullcrap interviews or
you know the backlighting or make you
something seem worse than it is I'm not
as bad as it is I want truth and you
can't find it maybe one website we can
find that yeah I don't know people ask
me oh that's one of the things people
ask me all the time is where do you get
your news how do you stay informed I
find I have to read just to figure out
what happened in one thing I usually
have to read about four or five
different stories and kind of piece it
all together because it's like
everybody's kind of giving you their own
brand of [ __ ] yeah and you got a
guess you gotta kind of put it together
like a an Einstein type for me to earn
and take a pun on what you think really
happened that's embarrassing and that's
that's kind of the reality of the world
we live
I read it I read almost every other day
mainstream media's if you was a falling
off the cliff and eventually it's it's
gonna be a minor number of people
watching that yeah I'm curious do you
guys in the locker room how much do you
guys talk about this kind of stuff I
would imagine this upcoming season
there's gonna be a lot of talk obviously
about black lives matter and I'm
guessing that there's probably gonna be
some players that aren't gonna stand for
the anthem that would just be my
suspicion do you guys get into that kind
of stuff in the locker room yeah I mean
one guy once he made who was with me in
gold as theories which media does
Harrison Barnes he's very involved with
political staff and reads a lot much
like myself so we we often disagree on
things but it's a prime example we will
debate and have a fun little debate
about it but it's not taken personally
you know as his side on things and I
have my side on things and but at the
end of the day it's an opinion and and
whatnot but I've obviously been you know
I'm a predominantly african-american Lee
so I have I have seen some things that
are you know pretty bad that a lot of
guys on my team have had to endure
growing up and heard some shocking
stories so I've kind of been on both
sides of it you know in Australia and
really you know even know the history of
what had happened and you know what are
these guys going up with with some you
know somewhat profiling with police and
all that kind of stuff so you know it's
it's tough from both sides because some
some guys on my team though you know
that the great guys and and they've
explained some of the pain you got to
deal with and you know it's it's not
great
yeah have you ever had I mean I get it
Harrison's a good guy and he can have
those conversations with you and and you
guys can put it aside
have you had teammates that you've
really gotten into it with where it's
just like we can't go there anymore
of course yeah of course I just don't I
just don't engages those guys you know
it's it's it's a losing battle but like
I said everyone's entitled to their
opinion but once once you realize that
someone can can't accept you or your
side of things or your argument without
without name-calling and all that kind
of stuff you kind of you can't just move
along and don't have to base yeah we
need some more centrist right I mean
everything you're you're basically
throwing at me here I'm actually not
even fully sure of your
real political beliefs yet I could ask
you something if you want but like you
strike me as just sort of a common-sense
centrist that that's really the one
thing that we don't have anymore
yeah and I'm stuck I've never party like
that I would vote for happily you know
and and I'm not I'm not cited to anybody
like I think all all our politicians are
full of [ __ ] you know they just stop
dying their campaigns to get votes
if you know and then I believe half the
stuff they're saying I'm just I've just
grown up in Australia it's very similar
selling broken promises car salesman
lawyer type attitude I just don't put my
faith in politicians I mean people that
do good luck to um but I've mentioned
this before I mean you know Joe blog
it's gets voted in tomorrow guess what
you still have to get up go to work
pick your kids up from school cook
dinner for the kids you know make sure
you watch happy or your husband's happy
and it's not gonna really change a whole
lot you still gonna go out there and
kind of you know sustain for yourself so
in a weird way is that sort of just how
Western society is designed to work like
it can sort of get to like a decent
level of goodness
doesn't mean we don't have things wrong
with our society but it gets to a place
then it just sort of by default has to
become corrupt and then it just kind of
either it'll either just stay there or
eventually crumble like there is no way
out of this kind of morass that we're in
you know I'm just asking you to solve
all of society's problems oh yeah I'll
get I'm a dumbass we don't need to shut
up probably this video going up so I'm
definitely prepared for that but it's
just one of those things you there's no
asset to it it's a tough one like I said
every day I I'm always gone try you know
try my best and what I'm doing work hard
for the family and all that and get on
with life I mean the petty stuff that
you know what gets me as well as the
social social justice warriors and
whatnot the stuff that I hear from fans
in a road game and I wouldn't change it
would you know they'd have to do a safe
space on the side of a bench or all the
triggering you know right
that's a part of sport grow up
you know what I mean like someone says
something bad or something you don't
agree with or offends you okay great you
offended me I can say something back I'm
moving on with my day
rather than trying to get that person
fired from their job or or whatever that
that's just ridiculous
[Music]
[Music]